foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
look at that look at that look at that
look at that that is
smarter than you what you think he's
smarter than you what you think he's
smarter
[Music]
look at that look at that look at that
man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man's a loser
business
[Music]
look at that Alex Jones is lying to you
that might come as a shop
[Music]
this is
something
[Music]
arrest tyranny look at that look at that
censorship debanking arrest tyranny
Linda corporate takeover censorship
demanding harass tyranny
[Music]
look at that
that's the loser Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man 's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
he's a disgrace he's a disgrace
[Music]
there's a story
light things
that did seem out of sight and now I
take it where I go
through every time I hear that theme
song ring it makes me wanna sing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you looking for a place to watch
some news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know of a guy who fits
that bill a progressive with political
will but David pectin shall see your
political knowledge growth sign up for
membership now for the bonus
who's the current president of the
United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'd rather not answer that how's that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive ducks
cost of the election
what is gone here what is the what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody at a massive
dumps cost from the election
what is going on here
dumps
[Music]
[Music]
jump jumps
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too nine nine cents okay
okay now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
sure sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it's a very very special day one of
the most anticipated debates of 2022 I
still don't believe it's happening I
won't believe it until I see Herschel
Walker on the stage moving his mouth
with audio visual elements coming out uh
because it's just not really clear to me
that he's really going to do this and as
many of you know one of the most
anticipated debates even before the
abortion Scandal and now in particular
because of the abortion Scandal and
questions about where does this uh race
go
in extraordinarily anticipated Herschel
Walker versus incumbent Democratic
senator Rafael Warnock starting in just
about 20 minutes and I love that people
are so fired up look at these numbers we
already have bully if the great smirko
Jiggy nasty questions Ace of Trace who
have signed up via twitch Prime as well
as face plant Cagers and also Daniel
beers Eric Smith Delana Bosworth and
Jason sickmeyer dumping in memberships
through my website putting us at 10
ladies and gentlemen just you wait for
what we are about to see here now before
people get ahead of themselves and think
that it's obviously over for Herschel
Walker
take a look at this polling
based on polls taken partially and
completely after the breaking of the
abortion scandal
Herschel Walker is only down by 3.3
think about how disgusting
a situation we have in this country
where you are a candidate who can't
explain your position on any issue
you lie constantly
you're completely unintelligible
you run on being a religious
conservative who is against abortion in
all cases
urge a woman to have two abortions
and your polling dips a little bit and
then recovers
it's what a country what a country we
have here
so this is going to be a very very
interesting debate to watch we are
looking at multiple streams and we will
get all of these streams uh tweaked and
prepared for you as we get closer to 7
PM but it is going to be a hell of a
debate if it happens if it happens
because there is still a chance
that there will be an empty lectern
remember people call it a Podium it's
not a Podium the podium is the platform
on which they stand
the thing is the lectern there may be an
empty lectern and we will continue
correctly addressing it as a lectern uh
okay where to even start super chats are
dumping in Cody says if a ping pong died
in Albany then why is gingivitis the
leading cause of lost tuna fish and red
SUV sales in 1974. yeah I mean we may
hear stuff like that at tonight's debate
do I ever check out my Discord deserve
server interesting happenings you know
occasionally I look at it once it once a
day roughly
um hey Gordy says Philip Kessler man I
don't even know what that means
wow
wow big thank you to Kevin gouldi for uh
sending in two gifted subscriptions I
really appreciate that very very much
folks this is a critical moment in this
election and I have an extraordinarily
important announcement to make
as many of you know we were banned from
tick tocks
we were supposedly banned because of
coveted disinformation and election
disinformation when in fact we were
debunking the misinformation we appealed
that and as I posted earlier to uh
Twitter we were told look at this look
at this after further review your
account will remain permanently banned
due to a violation of our adult nudity
and sexual activities policy folks
there is porn all over Tick Tock in
contravention of their policies
and we get banned for posting news
analyzes under the adult nudity policy
what are you talking about
at this point I completely lost all hope
and then all of a sudden
the accounts back
I have no idea why
I have no idea how all of a sudden
the account is back
and it's probably at risk of getting
banned
again
um let me see if I got a new message
here
from
no I don't okay
um no message from completely
inexplicable
it's just back
it's just back I don't know what to tell
you guys but uh it is what it is and we
are glad to be back although it may be
extraordinarily temporary other super
chats coming in
um
David Sir with tears in my eyes asks
Tara or Tara I'm dying to know what you
expect from tonight's debate I am
expecting first of all if the debate
happens I am expecting Herschel Walker
to repeat a handful of
um talking points and not substantively
answer any question
Bronx do you believe Reagan's story of a
local office that provided welfare that
cost more to pay the government workers
than it did to Simply feed the
impoverished people haven't heard it
not familiar with that one
1999 he weaves in a story about a bull
oh this person is betting that Herschel
Walker tells the story about bulls and
cows yeah maybe he will maybe he will
Mike pillow threatened Tick-Tock to sue
their machines our hero we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines the debate is just for the fans
right in warnock's backyard or whatever
yeah I I don't honestly I have no clue
what to expect from this debate by the
way I know people are joking around
saying oh grab the popcorn
I have popcorn guys and it is not just
regular popcorn I have spicy cheddar
popcorn because this debate I'm
expecting to be so good let's try it
oh that is spicy that is spicier than I
thought
dear God that is spicy okay I might have
to throw that out
uh okay let's see what else we have
okay if you check out your server once a
day been a test what was a recent debate
topic that plagued the server with over
4 000 comments no idea is was that the
circumcision thing maybe
I heard from the moderators that there
was an explosive circumcision element
if you're gonna get banned for adult
content anyway maybe it's time to start
an only fans I know right
David if you was the bull would you done
jumped over the fence and then looked
over and seen the Bulls and said ah nah
yeah I don't know that I still don't
really understand that story that
Raphael Warnock tells other um uh
significant gifts coming in thanks to
Thug Chuckles for the twitch Prime
subscription thanks to bully wife the
great for gifting five and thanks to
just Jamie and the ramen Raider guy for
the twitch Prime subscriptions putting
us at 20. also big thank you to Steve
Anderson and Simon Reed for signing up
at joinpakman.com putting us at 22. if
you're just coming in you have missed
nothing the debate hasn't started yet it
starts soon
I'm expecting Herschel to perform a few
steps down from Kelly Lefler I would say
so
I would say so that is my expectation as
well
uh let's look at a couple clips that I
had here for everybody
um let's see what we have
um
okay don't want to do the Tudor Dixon
stuff
not interested in the Cary Lake stuff
right now
oh boy Trump did not look good last
night huh that's weird
are friends the good liars with more of
their interviews what gets you so
excited about Donald Trump you're right
we're excited about not as a nurse in
the ER
working all this [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's not real because it's
bioterrorism and so are you are you
online in Jersey New York and Philly for
the first six months of this [ __ ]
what did you see
all kinds of stuff lots and lots of dead
people really well you know we also
we all crop dusters that didn't exist
before
you're saying this as like a
bioterrorist thing with crop dusters do
not see the crop dusters before the
pandemic started I notice you have a
Harry Potter shirt on yes sir I do do
you like Harry Potter do you like
fantasy oh really that's my truck right
there I'm a horcru she's Slytherin Dear
God
um Steve Cannon is Steve Cannon Steve
Bannon is now comparing Maga to the
victims of the Holocaust there's a nice
apt comparison huh you're right to
notice the slippery slope thing and by
the way I just want to say like as
always I told you this day would come
right I said then they come for the
children then they put people into
office right then they they have the
quarantine capsule so here we are in in
not just in Canada but in the United
States where the definition of murdering
a a child that has been born has gotten
innocent in two states
um
that they always start with life that
you can make a rationale that oh yes
people are so important kindness to do
away with them but then it's of course
you know whoever you don't like to use
dissidents gypsies homosexuals
um
folks under oh hello now listen uh Mega
just a throttle random just to throw at
a random concept I mean this is what I
remember when you listen
do people understand that there's a
difference between
discrimination
against people
for who they are
versus saying these people have
disgusting beliefs
and so we don't want to associate with
them right saying let's kill all the
Jews because they are
genetically Jewish
is very different than saying I find
your your opinions disgusting and I I
don't want you around me
right to be do people understand the
difference between those two things
or is that just me
God these people it's horrifying
horrifying horrifying stuff
let's see what else we got here
um
new ad from fetterman all right let's
Cho I'll bite after my stroke I was just
grateful to see Giselle and our kids
across Pennsylvania I keep seeing
families that don't have enough time to
focus on each other they're struggling
Left Behind we've got to make it easier
for people to spend time with those they
love
politicians spent so much time fighting
about the things that don't matter I'll
always be focused on what does access
the health care lower costs good jobs
more time with those we love I'm John
fetterman and I approve this message
pretty fine ad I mean you know I don't
know it's not it's nice I don't know
that it's going to move the needle
necessarily but a nice ad you can't
can't go wrong with that I guess
um let's see what else we have here
uh
Kanye stuff
the SanDisk we're not doing DeSantis
right now
see if I had anything else for everybody
Dr Oz nonsense maybe I don't have that
much else oh a new Don Jr segment
Democrat policies have failed us so
miserably that even
the son of a billionaire from Manhattan
can be pissed off when he's filling up
his truck and going to the grocery store
right
right that seems genuine doesn't it that
seems completely and totally genuine
from Don Jr
um yes
what a mess
oh this is the guy who claimed to spend
28 bucks at Taco Bell as a sign of how
much inflation there's been and he's now
being interviewed because a lot of
people are like 28 bucks at Taco Bell
that's not making a lot of sense I know
you posted a picture of your receipts uh
disproved that it was indeed a 28 bucks
right
yeah I took the order that I did and
basically put it in the app and took a
screenshot to show everybody because
that's what I typically order their
bouts and it adds up I mean what's funny
about it is there's a couple things
going on one is people thought it was a
lot of food it's actually not that much
it's very expensive food I'll give you
that there's a couple tacos on there
that are pushing like almost six bucks
and secondarily people are like oh it's
25 not 28 big difference number one
number two hello sales tax in Chicago
about 10 and a quarter percent bangs you
out at about 27. it banged him out there
okay let's see what they have here
um what do we have tacos
soft taco 1.69 soft taco supreme man
it's been like 25 years since I've been
to a Taco Bell
crunchy taco crunchy taco supreme
nacho cheese Doritos geez this isn't
seeming great I'm not gonna lie
combos
my Cravings box Mexican pizza combo
Jesus is this is this even legal
Crunchwrap Supreme wait so what is all
this Dorito stuff does that mean that
the shells are basically Dorito chips is
that what that is
is that what that means oh my God so
it's basically they're using potato
chips as the taco shells that is
shocking
that is that is Criminal burrito
bean burrito double steak
this is this is pretty freaking bad
wow all right well anyway 28 bucks I
guess you could you could spend there
seemingly it's dystopian it's quite
frankly quite frankly it is dystopian
thanks to Jason sickmeyer and Thomas
Tosh for gifting two subscriptions on my
website thanks to William trasillo and
Sarah wallsworth for signing up as well
that's four new subscribers putting us
at 26 also really appreciate over on
Twitch guitar goddess and bilbro wagons
bilbro swaggins for the twitch Prime
subscriptions folks if you're just
joining us we are moments moments
moments away from this debate I have
only one request of you this is like the
sixth debate we are streaming and we've
got like 10 more coming up Justin what's
left of this election season we really
do depend on our audience for what we do
get a membership on my website okay look
at how easy this nonsense is this is so
easy to do you go to joinpakman.com you
can do monthly you can do yearly you hit
sign up you then can enter a coupon code
if you want here's a sample coupon code
see where it says above my head big
voting 22 big voting 22. you type it in
you get a criminal discount if you want
an even better discount you use the
coupon code Obama Obama foreign look at
this folks look at this and you can also
do monthly every single person that
signs up I will eat one of my kernels of
spicy popcorn and I will say your name
okay it's such a special day
it's powerful
it's important it's beautiful okay and I
will spend 28 bucks at Taco Bell
no I'm just kidding yeah I know people
are saying order some Doritos tacos
um oh wait a second I also think I have
hold on did I did I have a
we have to keep our country gay people
but it's not I mean no hold on I thought
I had a thing about my discounts I enjoy
your little machine sarcasm no God I
don't have I can't find it all right
yeah I'll order a one Crunchwrap Supreme
for every new membership no I'm kidding
about that that I'm very very much
kidding about okay let's look at a few
other super chats here sir did you
thought over my trump calling rally
media fake news Newsmax not broadcasting
Theory
remember yesterday greetings again I I
apologize MH I did not but I will
uh thanks to sjd will Herschel Walker
lay out the details of his plan to
create a department that monitors young
men watching women watching social media
yeah you guys want to see that clip
that's a hell of a clip
um
let me see if I can find that here
Herschel
Walker Manu Raju
let's see if we can find that
no uh social media
here it is there's some will in that
weapon you know Kane Kia Abel you know
and uh you know that's the problem that
we have and I said what we need to do is
look into how we can stop those things
you know he talked about doing a
disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at uh women that looking
at uh just social media right we need a
department by the way small government
right an entire department that will
just look at young men looking at young
women looking at social media that's
that's crazy that's uh that's big
government not small government
um okay bring my tacos back down don't
raise the price of tacos I agree David
sir how can you claim Walker isn't a
family man he started at least nine
families that screams honesty and family
values well said yeah well said
tomorrow's headline Senator Warnock
embarrasses Herschel walk around debate
stage polls unchanged basically that's
more or less what I'm expecting
it it's really sad but unfortunately
it's sort of what I'm expecting
did you hear about the Fox News
financial advisor that blamed inflation
for why the Taco Bell lunch was 28 yes
we just played that clip we were just
looking at that clip let's listen to a
little more of his explanation and 46 I
think so it's all there so were you
surprised uh how much love you got I'm
going to play Assad people out there
listen
dude said he ate 28 worth of Taco Bell
when he heard from him since you can't
eat 28 worth of Taco Bell on a work day
I mean he called in today for Fox
Business you can't do a live hit with 28
a Taco Bell in your stomach like that
man somebody check on that man like you
got what they call it a wellness check
you had to do a wellness check like when
you ain't heard from your loved one in a
while the police got a robot I bet the
police go by the house right now
hahaha
that's like the Tucker laugh right
see if we can find that hold on
so Kamala Harris is a charmless phony
who has such total and utter contempt
for your intelligence that she fully
expects you to believe that her fake
laugh is real
and that's bad but think of what Alex
could do with that material it would be
amazing for cable news now diversity
that's uh the face of militarism
hahaha
I just love that in case you haven't
noticed it's like boarded up
that's more my concern but I appreciate
it there's nothing you can do about it
so Kamala Harris is a charmless phony
who oh man anyway I I can't I can't do
it any longer I mean it's just it's too
it's too much it's too much it's crazy
um okay
folks
something is happening on our website
where the website is barely keeping up
with everybody who's signing up Hunter
White
Jason sigmeyer Leslie maley Mary Carmen
Garcia
Alora Smith Tommy horse swill Jennifer
Stewart and Brad bronstein Christopher
Mund and Holly butcher Jennifer walner
Hans lynesh Scott McKinnon Jacqueline
asansi Jose Ortiz Howard Love Deborah
Sanchez Matt Bellmore
oh my God Donna Williams Grace McElroy
and John turcotte have all how many is
that one two three four five six seven
eight
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21
21 memberships dumping in immediately
putting us at 49.
I really appreciate that
I really appreciate that as we just have
moments left until this debate let's see
if we can just squeeze in squeeze in a
voicemail
but you know I'm really thankful for you
know a couple to you know try to make uh
you know a valuable effort to stay
connected and
um you know to achieve that
um look of
I can't remember what's it called okay
here is uh the Eggman
Dennis prager's sister is totally hot
Shalom wow the Eggman really really
diving in there with a lot that's a lot
from the Eggman
um and let's see what else I have here
uh
hi David I have a thought question that
has been rolling around in my brain for
a while
I'm just wondering if Marjorie Taylor
green could be our first
female president yeah you know what's
funny about that the first female
president might actually be a right-wing
nut and there's we've talked about this
before and it is sad it is very very sad
uh we are moments away from the start of
this debate what else can I squeeze in
here before we start really not much
I'll thank a couple other people thanks
to Deborah hen Ingrid Ori John lobideck
and Calvin Martin for signing up on my
website I really do appreciate that
putting us at 53 the ticker will
continue to climb if you're just joining
us we've been covering so many of these
debates if you're watching on Twitch
make sure you're following us if you're
watching on YouTube make sure you are
subscribed uh because we we've got more
debates coming we've got the Ron Ron
death santis debate we've got uh they're
just so so many debates as we stand by
for this debate and as soon as we know
exactly where we will be watching it I
will get us a beautiful full screen
video so don't worry about that we are
going to see it however if the debate
doesn't start in the next couple of
minutes I will start to wonder whether
Rafael Warnock maybe just didn't show up
which was a concern there there are
until I see him on the stage I'm not
going to be convinced that he's actually
showing up and I hope that I am very
very much wrong about that uh I hope
that he's here I hope he debates I hope
he participates I hope he substantively
answers questions thanks to Andre
Bavaria and betazoid for the twitch
Prime subscriptions Jeff in Boston also
just gifted five subscriptions on Twitch
which I very much appreciate uh thanks
also to Martina and Brian Newberry and
Theresa deller who just signed up on my
website the debate expected to run one
hour one hour and one hour only we will
see where it's starts first I am hopeful
that we are not going to see Raphael
Warnock alone
standing at an empty standing next to an
empty lectern people saying is this
really happening it appears to really be
happening it appears to really be
happening but again
where are the candidates it was supposed
to have started a minute ago
and I am not seeing it I'd rather spend
that extra 30 on food and diapers and
you gotta eat so you have to pay for it
abortion gun violence and health care
okay hearing candidates with two
different Visions for your future Joe
Biden and Raphael Warner I'm gonna get
this set up for us okay guys people of
Georgia have a
real Choice give me a second about who
they think is ready to represent them
vying for your vote the first black
senator to represent the state of
Georgia Democrat Rafael Warnock you sent
me back to the Senate you have my word I
will keep fighting working
businessman and Heisman Trophy winner
Republican Herschel Walker they have no
doubt we have problems in this country
who do you trust in Washington every
word these men it sort of seems like
it's happening guys wow welcome
everybody Riverside District in Savannah
this is the Georgia U.S Senate debate
welcome to debate night in America I'm
your host Leland Vitter from news nation
in 2020. I've been on Fox news I've been
interviewed by this guy Leland Vitter
Senate and it might well again the
stakes could not be higher tinataya Shaw
anchor at wsav here in Savannah and buck
landford anchor at Fox you know what in
Atlanta we'll moderate tonight's debate
I'm going to switch to this guys
in Atlanta we'll moderate tonight this
is better we are joined by a live studio
audience they have agreed to hold their
cheers and Applause
tonight's debate we also welcome our
viewers across the country watching on
news nation and voters here in Georgia
joining us on five next star stations
and several partner stations across the
region
before we get started with tonight's
topics the rules here we go Senator
Warnock Mr Walker you will each have 60
seconds for opening statements and 60
seconds to answer each question if
there's a follow-up or rebuttal you will
have 30 seconds when time's up you'll
hear this Bell
each candidate will also have 60 seconds
for a closing statement and with that it
is time to get underway Tina and buck
the floor is yours
Leland thank you very much Senator
Warnock Mr Walker good evening to you
both we appreciate you being here it's
happening forward to hearing from you
both tonight and for those of you at
home that are following along we'd like
for you to use the hashtag
g-a-s-e-n debate once again it's hashtag
g-a-s-e-n debate good to see you as well
Gentlemen We Begin tonight with opening
statements a card draw determined who
will go first Mr Walker we will begin
with you you have 60 seconds
first I like to acknowledge my Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ I'm one of seven
kids born and raised in Wrightsville
Georgia my parents taught me about faith
family education and the love of country
they also taught me about a good work
ethic and because of that I found the
America's dream but this race ain't
about me it's about what Raphael went
out and Joe Biden had done to you and
your family tonight he's going to try to
Sweet talkie that he's doing a good job
but his record speaks for itself I'm
here to tell you that they've raised
your taxes gave you high inflation they
even put men in women's sports
and I want to let you know the referral
one night we're giving six more years
think what he's going to do
so I'm here to fix it
Mr Walker thank you Senator Warnock we
turn now to you for your opening
statement you have 60 Seconds
well thank you so very much and hello
Georgia it's so wonderful to be back
here in my hometown now I know that
we're in a debate tonight but really I
come with a deep heart filled with
gratitude probably because I grew up
about a mile from here in the Caton
homes housing projects
I'm one of 12 children in my family
clearly my preacher parents read the
Bible be fruitful and multiply
when I think about the Ark of my life
the short distance and the long distance
from there to here I know that only in
America is my story possible my family
taught me the importance of hard work
and how to build the Beloved Community
that Dr King used to talk about and I
brought that Spirit to the Senate at the
end of the day this race is about who's
ready to represent Georgia in the U.S
Senate I think that choice is clear and
I look forward to having that discussion
tonight
thank you Senator Warnock gentlemen we
have a lot to get to this hour so we
will start tonight with the most
important issues facing Georgia voters
our next star Emerson College the hill
poll shows the economy threats to
democracy and abortion access are the
top three issues we're going to begin
tonight with the economy everyday
Georgians are struggling they're
struggling to pay for food gas Child
Care housing this week the inflation
rate continues to rise Mr Walker we're
going to start with you you've been
openly critical blaming President Biden
and the Democrats for inflation and for
the economy if elected what is one idea
one idea that you would Champion to
reduce inflation we ask you to be
specific you have one idea specific well
first of all you have to blame this
Administration and Senator or not
because and within two years this
inflation has gotten worse they are cut
our energy uh Independence they also
raise taxes but at the same time they're
Reckless spending too much money so he
would sit here tonight and say that he's
doing a good job for us and you asked me
what is one job I would do to help the
inflation one idea first of all we got
to become independent or energy
independent again and the reason why
we're going to our enemies to ask for
gas and oil and that puts us not just in
a inflation problem but it put us on a
national security problem and I think
that's something that I think Senator
Warner need to realize and he mentioned
that he grew up here in Savannah with 12
siblings with 12 siblings well in this
area most people live paycheck to
paycheck and we have inflation the way
he's brought inflation on how in the
world can you buy groceries or gas for
your family a follow-up question to that
Mr Walker most economists say that
cutting government spending is the first
step in economic recovery I would want
to ask you would you consider cutting
military funding or spending on social
services to accomplish his goal I would
not uh think about cutting military
spending because first I believe in
peace through strength right now we're
at a break of war and I think right now
we're it Senator Warner who he and Joe
Biden they don't show any strength and
we have to protect this country and we I
said it early on right now because we're
giving out energy energy up to our
enemies that don't like us we have to be
ready for war this is not uh he first
said we were getting energy from our
enemies now he's saying we're giving
energy to our enemies what which is it
by just taking office inflation it's
reached levels that we haven't seen in
40 years you've supported nearly every
piece of legislation that this
Administration has pushed through
Congress do you take any responsibility
for the financial hardships currently
that Georgians are facing and you have
60 seconds
there's no question that people are
feeling pain
at the grocery store at the pump at
Pharmacy counters and while we are
paying record prices
a lot of our corporate actors are seeing
record profits in the oil and gas
industry and the pharmaceutical industry
which is why I stood up for ordinary
hard-working Georgia families time and
time again
I passed the single largest tax cut
contrary to what my opponent is
suggesting for middle and working class
families in American history and we
passed the inflation reduction act which
had two of my Provisions one caps the
cost of prescription drugs for seniors
so they don't have to choose between
buying medicine and buying groceries and
one caps the cost of insulin he said he
would not have voted for the inflation
reduction act and I think he should tell
the people in Georgia why he thinks they
should have expensive insulin and while
the pharmaceutical company should be
able to charge us whatever they like
well first of all may I respond you know
I believe in reducing insulin but at the
same time you got to eat right because
he may not know and I know many people
that's on insulin and unless you have an
eating right insulin is doing you no
good be so you have to get food prices
down and you got to get gas down so they
can go get insulin and you continue to
patch yourself on the back but right now
families are starving he's arguing that
the price of insulin doesn't matter
because the price of gas is high so when
you drive to the insulin it's expensive
Senator Warnock I'll give you an
opportunity listen I I meet people all
the time in my church who are trying to
manage their diabetes I've been there
when they've gotten the news and they've
got to get an amputation and I think
we're hearing from my opponent tonight
that it's their fault
that prices of insulin are being gouged
I I don't think it's their fault I think
it's the fault of these pharmaceutical
companies insulin's been around 100
years the patent was sold for one dollar
they're engaged in price gouging and too
many people in Washington think they
work for the pharmaceutical companies I
work for the people of Georgia he's in
Washington can I finish I work for the
people yeah were you in Washington and
that's why I stand up every year and
you're the leader Mr Walker let's move
forward if we can a follow-up question
to you senator in 30 seconds Georgia
need help right now and your opinion is
the answer another stimulus check or is
there a better option out there to deal
with this right now we pass the
inflation reduction Act
he's already told you he would vote
against it
he's he's already told you that he
doesn't believe in capping the costs of
prescription drugs for people like my 84
year old mother no I don't think they
should I don't believe in him
let's let him talk we'll get a second I
don't think she should have to choose
between buying medicine and buying
groceries and that's why I've stood up
for her and I've stood up for
hard-working families every single day
and I've stood against the corporations
that are being bad actors they're seeing
record profits in the middle of a
pandemic and who exploits a pandemic
gentlemen we need to move on to our next
Topic in the interest of time so that's
election Integrity Tina it's all yours
all right Buck thank you Senator Warnock
this question is for you you have said
the new Georgia voting laws implemented
after the 2020 election create many
obstacles for underserved communities
yet there was record turnout in Georgia
in the primary this may according to
research done by the Brennan Center for
justice the African-American vote grew
approximately 50 percent from 2018 to
2022's primaries Senator can you explain
how the law negatively impacts minority
votes you have 60 seconds Sir
so I have spent my whole career long
before coming to the Senate fighting for
voting rights because I believe that a
vote is a kind of Prayer for the world
we desire for ourselves and for our
children we register people to vote in
my church
and in the Senate I've stood up for
democracy because that's the framework
in which we get to fight for all of the
things we care about there is no
question
that SB 202 makes voting harder and that
is the intent and the fact that many of
our voters are overcoming this hardship
doesn't undermine that reality
they've made it harder for folks to use
the drop boxes they've shortened uh the
registration times
folks are saying you know you shouldn't
have to not you should be able to get
food or water in a line I think the
question is more fundamental than that
why are the line so long in certain
communities and not others and so I just
want to encourage Georgia voters to keep
showing up don't let anybody take your
voice don't let anybody take your vote
it took too much to get here and I'm on
it to represent you in the United States
Senate Senator Warnock thank you Mr
Walker we move to you now in 2020
Georgia became the epicenter for
questions on voter fraud we'd like to
hear your thoughts in 60 seconds did
President Biden defeat former president
Donald Trump in 2020 again sir you have
60 seconds well first of all I need to
mention that he said that uh SB 202
really it made it easier to vote and
harder to cheat and she mentioned that
uh more people turned out for the
primary so you gotten good in Washington
not answering that question because that
was the question she asked you and did
President uh bite win
that's the reason I decided to run
because we need a change in Washington
we need leaders that's going to stand up
to uh foreign leaders we need people
that's going to stand up for people in
Georgia because Senator we're not he
went to Washington but he forgot about
Georgia and I want to stand for the
people of Georgia he just mentioned he's
standing for the people of Georgia but
can he tell me why he voted with Joe
Biden 96 percent of the time if he was
standing for Georgia that tells you that
he's for Joe Biden I'm for Georgia
Mr Walker thank you now before we move
on I'd like to respond to that I will
give you that opportunity sir I will
give you that opportunity Senator you
have 15 seconds to respond it is very
clear that my opponent would rather be
running against anybody except me
yeah
who are going to sit in this seat either
me
or my opponent and I think this race is
about who's ready to represent the
people of Georgia and I'm thinking about
them every single day but if he cut from
the same cloth at 96 percent of the time
I'm running he and Joe Biden because
they're the same oh my God gentlemen
gentlemen we are moving on now this is
this next question this is a yes or no
response and this is for both of you
Senator Warnock yes or no regardless of
who wins in November will you accept the
outcome yes
and Mr Walker regardless of who wins in
November will you accept the idea
thank you very much gentlemen Buck over
to you thank you Tina we turned out to
the topic of abortion we're going to
start with you Mr Walker a week before
this debate a former girlfriend made
public accusation saying you paid for an
abortion and that you encouraged her to
have another in an ABC news interview
this week you said that the accusations
are quote all lies for the voters
watching tonight can you explain the
circumstances surrounding these claims
you have 60 seconds well as I said
that's a lie and you know well most
things I put I put it in a book one
thing about my life is I've been very
transparent right not like the senator
he's here things he said at the same
time I said that's a lie and on abortion
you I'm a Christian I believe in life
and I tell people this Georgia is a
state that respects life and I'll be a
senator that protects life and I say
that was a lie and I'm not backing down
and we have Senator Warner people that
would do anything and say anything for
this seat but I'm not going to back down
it's too important to Georgia people for
me to back down right now what a liar
you've been vocally pro-life supporting
a ban on abortions without exceptions
would you support a complete ban on a
national level first of all see that's
not true either I say I support uh a
heartbeat bill and I say I support the
Georgia heartbeat bill because that's
the bill of the people from Governor Kim
and I said that has exceptions in it I
said I'm a Christian but I'm also
representing the people of Georgia and
that's who I represent so what the
people of Georgia stand for I'm going to
stand with them
thank you Mr Walker Senator Warnock you
said repeatedly that the exam room is
too small for the patient her doctor and
the U.S how do you not follow up and go
but
she's the mother of one of your kids you
acknowledge that part right and so you
know her and right and you have 60
seconds I think that the women of this
country and the women of this state
woke up one summer morning
and a core protection that they've known
for 50 years
was taken from them by an extremist
Supreme Court
and I stand where I I've said I stand in
the past that a patient's room is too
narrow and small and cramped a space for
a woman her doctor and the United States
government we are witnessing right now
what happens when politicians most of
most of them men
pile into patients rooms
you get what you're seeing right now
and the women of Georgia
the women of Georgia deserves a senator
who will stand with them
I trust women more than I trust
politicians may I may I respond very
quickly
you know it is and I heard about him
today I heard he was he was he's a neat
talker but did he not mention that there
was a baby in that room as well and they
also did not mention paperwork that he
asked him that he asked him the taxpayer
to pay for it so he's bringing the
government back into the room so he's
not talking about that there's no
taxation you mentioned that it's like
I've not seen too many Pastor ever say
that statement
I am a pastor
I'm a man of faith
and I have a profound reverence for life
and a deep respect for choice and
because I have such a profound reference
for life it's one of the reasons why
I've stood up to address this issue of
maternal mortality in our country
we lead all of the western Nations on
that front and black women are three to
four times more likely to die even when
they have the insurance and the income
now that's something government could
actually do something about and I joined
with Marco Rubio of Florida
to pass a bill to address maternal
mortality the women of Georgia have a
clear choice
as we're watching women die do you want
a senator who wants to control your life
or do you want a senator who wants to
save your life well I want to save your
life well it was funny
lives matter
and if you think about it senator in
Atlanta Georgia there's more black baby
that is aborted
give you a chance to respond to that I I
think the women of Georgia
have a clear choice he says no
exceptions
even in the case of rape
incest
or the life of the mother I think that's
extreme is out of touch with Georgia
and I intend to do the work that
Senators can do the heaters
exceptions for that in the heartbeat
bill so when he murdered
a follow-up question for you Senator
Warnock we ask that you take a listen to
something that you said at a rally just
a couple of weeks ago
so women I trust women in their wisdom
and their ability to sit with their own
doctor that's right and if they choose
to sit with their pastor
and to pray about that and let their own
conscience guide them
even God gave us a choice
even God gave us a choice can you
clarify what you meant by that you have
30 seconds oh I think it's it's
self-explanatory
God gave us a choice and I respect
uh the right of women to make a decision
these are medical decisions they are
deeply personal
women find themselves in a range of
circumstances
and this issue has been far too
politicized and we're witnessing right
now the chaos that ensues as a result of
that
and women right now
who may be facing a miscarriage in some
cases a wondering what will happen and
how will they have to explain that I
think that's deeply problematic there
are enough politicians piling into the
rooms of patience
and I don't plan to join them but just
to clarify in your opinion God gave us a
choice in regards to abortion it is
apparent that God has given us a range
of choices
and the people of Georgia have a choice
right now about who they think should
represent them in the Senate and man may
I have to respond we do have to move
back to our next to be very short very
short because he's correct God gave us a
choice but also within the Bible if you
read the Bible more God said choose life
in the Bible it says I give you a choice
just like Adam and Eve had a choice but
they chose death God says
I think he wants to arrogate to
politicians more power than God has all
right gentlemen thank you we're gonna
have to move on to our next topic okay
Tina okay we are moving on gentlemen on
the next topic and it is about student
loans we turn to Christian dent a
college student and Next Star News
Nation viewer from Locust Grove Georgia
as a college student at the University
of Georgia me and my peers are often
faced with confronting the rising costs
that come with obtaining a college
degree in the United States Senate will
you support further forgiveness of
student loan debt and if so how you
implement it in the United States Senate
on a federal level
our thanks to Christian for that
question Senator Warnock your answer
please in 60 Seconds
I wouldn't be standing here tonight if
it weren't for low-interest student
loans
and Pell Grants
and in the years since I've graduated
that path has gotten harder I ran into a
couple on a flight
and they wrote a note for me they were
with their one-year-old son they said
whatever you do please do something
about the student debt the mother said I
borrowed 35
000 I paid back twenty thousand I still
owe thirty thousand and that's why I
pushed the president to do student debt
relief he did ten thousand dollars and
with my urging he did twenty thousand
for folks with Pell Grants I think it
was the right move it will spur
entrepreneurship home ownership it helps
kids in technical schools and vocational
schools not just four-year colleges but
we need reform we we shouldn't be doing
this again 10 years from now and I'm
working right now on the kind of Reform
we need because college is outpacing uh
the price of everything else in our
economy a follow-up for you sir why do
you believe this should be done through
executive action instead of Congress and
also how would this be funded you have
30 seconds
the president has already moved to do
student debt relief and um there's
additional relief for folks like me who
when they got student loans uh were Pell
Grant eligible but there's no question
we need reform in the system so that we
can get the cost of college underway we
don't find ourselves here again uh and
that's my position thank you Senator
Warnock thank you Mr Walker to repeat
Christian's question will you support
further forgiveness of student loan debt
and if so how would you implement it
well first of all uh you can see 60
seconds Sir I apologize first of all you
can see that Senator has gotten good at
being in Washington because you asked
the question why did congress not do it
instead of the president doing an
executive order which is what should
have been done and as I was traveling
around the state of Georgia I talked to
people some people want to go to college
they couldn't
so they end up going and working up
father's form okay military wanted to go
to college they didn't so he went to the
military may have lost the arm
so this is not right
Georgia people say it's not right
and I and I they said it's unfair first
of all how can you transfer someone that
who owe it to someone that don't owe it
and also Senator we're not bribes about
making 400 billion dollars that now the
taxpayer all you in the audience got to
pay for you got to pay that debt and I
didn't co-sign for anyone's loan I hope
no one out here cosigned for anyone long
because I didn't co-sign for anyone loan
and it's not right it's not fair
Mr Walker we're continuing with a
follow-up for you now Mr Walker College
tuition it skyrocketed 175 percent over
the past 20 years what will you do to
stem the cost of higher education going
forward well first you have 30 seconds
first of all what you should do is uh
get rid of federal funding of any
college that raise their costs you're
ready to get rid of federal federal
funding than any college that raise
their costs that's the first thing that
you should do what so that is what you
would do
well any college that raised their costs
I get rid of any federal funding that
they're going to get
I will be very brief I promise very
brief
it's interesting to me that that folks
who have been crying about the student
debt relief haven't said anything about
multi-billionaire corporate entities
who've gotten PPP loans
I wonder why Mr uh uh oh we're going to
move on we're moving on thank you thank
you so much
Mr Walker we are moving on we're going
to move on to minimum wage gentlemen we
have a lot to get through tonight we've
made that clear at the top of the hour
so let's get as many questions as we can
in because Georgia voters want to know
where you stand on these issues they
have to make a decision let them know
tonight Buck thank you Tina now
according to the U.S census real quick
let me know in the chat who's winning
the debate so far the federal minimum
wage is 7.25 cents an hour a number that
has not increased since 2009. let's do
this by a simple showing of hands raise
your hand if you support a federal
minimum wage
okay Mr Walker you did not raise your
hand so I'd like to ask you first of all
why not and what would you do to help
struggling Georges well I mean you said
a federal
um
I think right now and he said that I
want the federal government no he wants
a federal government to run your life
right now I think you have to work with
different corporations and see just
where they can pay there's some
companies right now and he should know
this after getting the All-Star Game
moved out of Atlanta they destroyed a
lot of small businesses oh my God so
those businesses couldn't pay 15 20 an
hour so they have to pay what they're
capable of paying so to mandate a
federal
uh Federal uh fee that they have to pay
hourly wage no I couldn't I couldn't
approve that what thank you Mr Walker
Senator Warnock you did not raise your
hand so why not and what would you do to
help struggling Georgia I I believe in
the Dignity of work
and I believe in the Dignity of workers
I watched my dad work really hard to
take care of his family what's a federal
fee call Essential workers these folks
are on the front line stand up for us in
the midst of the pandemic we call them
essential workers they deserve an
essential wage and essential benefits in
other words workers deserve to
participate in the prosperity that they
are creating for others and so I've been
a part of this conversation around the
minimum wage I think people need a
livable wage
and some of that is being addressed
right now in this strong labor market so
I'm willing to work with folks in the
corporate Community as well as the labor
Community to feel that to figure out how
we get to a good place but there's no
question people deserve to participate
in the prosperity that they're creating
for others they deserve a livable wage
and they deserve benefits thank you
Senator Warnock we're going to move to
our next topic Tina and that topic is
crime and violence in June Congress
passed the first bipartisan legislation
to combat gun violence in 30 years
according to a Pew research poll
released in July 78 percent of Americans
think the new gun law will do little or
nothing to reduce gun violence Senator
Warren I could turn to you first as the
number of shootings in Georgia and
Across the Nation continue to rise what
should be done what should the next step
be to solve this issue you have to
answer this question sir and I give you
one minute
we finally passed the first gun safety
law in 30 years
and we did that on a bipartisan basis
I believe that this law will indeed save
lives and I'd like to see us work and
see what we can achieve beyond that on a
bipartisan basis my heart goes out when
I see the kinds of tragedies that we are
witnessing all across our state all
across our country
and it's the reason why I have passed
legislation to support law enforcement I
passed the largest investment in the
cops program in a decade I introduced
legislation called investor protect
that's endorsed by the sheriffs of Burke
County and Screven County because
because it supports some of our smaller
law enforcement entities so we've got to
stand up with law enforcement but we've
also got to create opportunity Senator
Warnock thank you Mr Walker we're posing
the same question to you sir in one
minute what should the next step be to
solve gun violence well first of all uh
you know any uh
law of bill passed that'll affect
anyone's Second Amendment I'm not going
to stand for and I want support but
third to hear Senator talks about
supporting lawyer he went from a second
amendment to third even though it was
the first thing oh that is a genius
thing the name caller he's done the rail
is down recruitment is down only because
of what he's done he's empowered
criminals
to think they're better than the police
and because he believes in no cash bail
is releasing prisoners he don't protect
the Border fentanyl is coming to this
country and also into Atlanta
70 of the drugs coming from the border
goes to Atlanta Georgia
and he talks about
the police now I have more Sheriff that
has endorsed me than anyone running in
in Georgia right now and I even have
some sheriffs here and they've endorsed
me because they know I have their back
they're going to have my bags so to
listen to him say that after calling him
name I think question was about gun
violence Mr Walker thank you I have a
follow-up now
I think ought to be able to respond to
that I will give you the opportunity
we will see time and time again tonight
as we've already seen
that my opponent has a problem with the
truth
I
I true
our police officers
I've called them and I've prayed with
their families like those officers lost
in Cobb County
when they were killed doing what police
officers routinely do
you can support police officers as I've
done through the cops program through
the invest to protect program while at
the same time holding police officers
like all professions accountable one
thing I have not done I've never
pretended to be a police officer
right and and I've never I've never
threatened a shootout with the police
correctly respond to that and you know
what's so funny I am with many police
officers and at the same time Mr Walker
Mr Walker Mr Walker excuse me Mr Walker
I need to let you know Mr Walker you are
very well aware of the rules tonight yes
and you have a prop that is not allowed
sir I ask you to put that prop away but
it's not a problem this is real and he
said I have a problem
Mr Walker excuse me sir yes you're very
well aware of the rules aren't you well
are you aware let's talk about the truth
thank you for putting that prop away and
as a matter of fact we still have a lot
to get to and we are not going to
continue this we're going to follow up
with a question and this is according to
the CDC homicide is the leading cause of
death for African-American youth Mr
Walker in 30 seconds why do you believe
this is happening and what would you do
to stop it well what I would do is hold
people accountable which is centered why
not do it believing in no cash Bail no
accountability that is a problem people
must be accountable for their action and
the truth lies with Senator Warner
because he said he was doing the
Washington to represent Georgia not even
he went to Washington to represent Joe
Biden that's the reason we're in the
midst we're in today because we
represent Joe Biden and not the truth
for Georgia
Senator Warnock this follow-up for you
same question what do you believe
homicides among African-American youths
is growing why are those homicides
growing sir and how do we stop it
well it's heartbreak breaking
and I've seen this up close as a pastor
I presided over some of these funerals
I've met with young people
and we have to have rules and laws in
the society which I support and I've
invested in as a legislator at the same
time we have to create opportunity
there's no sickness like the loss of
Hope
when people lose hope when when they
when they doubt that their life can be
any longer or or that they can
a dream of something bigger than the
street they live on
a lot of things can happen I grew up in
one of those neighborhoods but I had a
nurturing family and I benefited from
good Federal public policy like the Head
Start program like Upward Bound
like Pell Grants and low interest
student loans and to invest in our
children guys I'm sorry when they said
that's a prop and he said it's not a
prop it's it's real that that is just
it's an unbelievable moment and we're
gonna shift gears a little bit here
Senator hafka-esque honey you tweeted
this unemployment benefits have expired
rent is due and many Georgia families
are at risk of eviction my opponents are
supposed to be serving the people in
Washington but they are clearly
concerned with their own interests well
recent published Reports say talk about
a property that your church owns
Columbia Towers at MLK Village in
Atlanta it's a home for the
disadvantaged at least a dozen lawsuits
have been filed by residents evicted for
not being able to pay their rent some of
the outstanding balances are less than
thirty dollars as someone who receives
more than seven thousand dollars a month
for a housing allowance from Ebenezer
Baptist Church how do you explain this
to Georgia voters who are struggling
currently to make ends meet
well let me say that
serving in the United States Senate and
continuing to serve by Church
is the honor of my life
and it gives me a lens through which to
do the work that I'm doing but here's
why you know I'm running against a
desperate candidate
anytime a candidate would stoop to the
level of trying to Sully the name he and
his allies to Sully the name of Martin
Luther King Jr's Church
and John Lewis's Church
you know that's a desperate candidate
let me tell you about my church uh-oh my
church is a Matthew 25 Church
we spend every week every day feeding
the hungry and the homeless
they know that those false charges that
they've created are not true
we we stand up for poor people every
single day and I ran for the Senate to
do it a policy level what we do at a
local level every single day I'm not
going to be distracted by him and his
allies
my people know the truth they know the
work we do every single day and I
couldn't be prouder of them proud to
represent the Senate and proud to serve
Ebenezer Baptist Church so just to
clarify your position is that the
allegations and these lawsuits are not
true I I am saying that it is very
obvious
that my opponent and his allies are busy
trying to Sully Ebenezer Baptist Church
oh boy
the truth
switch your gears a little bit here sir
your ex-wife filed a lawsuit asking for
increased child support not good saying
that she had to pay for child care on
days that your duties as a senator
interfered with your parenting time and
citing significant increases in your
income in 30 seconds what is your
response to that lawsuit
listen I um I went through a divorce
like a lot of people
and while that was a painful period what
came out of that
was two amazing children
that I just talked to before I came on
the stage
and my children know that I am with them
and for them and that I support them in
every single way
that a father does
thank you Senator Warnock now to you Mr
Walker recent ads have highlighted
allegations of past domestic violence
they've raised questions about how
transparent you've been as far as your
resume in one minute how do you respond
to voters who question your integrity
both personally and professionally uh
first of all I've been very transparent
it's kind of a song I'm not ashamed to
admit it and I say I had a mental
problem and I'd be a champion for mental
health because so many people suffer
from mental health but to have people
like sinner or not the demonize mental
health when I want to tell everyone out
there you can get help don't listen to
Senator Warner and his people you can
get help all you got to do is ask all
you got to do is ask but the problem
with the truth you just saw it you just
saw it because he won't answer that
about evicted the people from the church
and I told them I would pay that I'll
pay their salary you evicting them right
now
we have not evicted we have not evicted
those I didn't write the article wait
you you're
and and he should take that money and
pay it back to the veterans that he
exploited while pretending the run and
uh see you can tell that he's not
desperate because if he had read in that
thing he would have sold it I had
nothing to do with that but he is so
desperate right now and he really want
that seat he's now telling you I didn't
evict anyone it is written in the paper
I didn't do this well Senator you did
and it's okay to speak the truth do not
bear false witness Senator do not bear
false witness if it's true because it's
in an article then the abortion story
about Walker is true right for uh
Senator Warnock we need to move forward
here you have been very open about your
struggles with mental illness and you
even wrote a book about dissociative
your diagnosis of disassociative
identity disorder we recently asked if
you were still receiving treatment and
this is is what you had to say no that's
all done and you don't need to and
that's why I tell people I think one
thing I told people is I've been open
about I don't need trees I was open
about it what 14 years ago
Mr Walker in 30 seconds can you clarify
this are you saying you no longer have
disassociative identity disorder or is
this something that you continue to this
day no you don't have to have treatment
for it and I encourage people to
continue to talk to people you know I
talk to my pastors I talk to my pastors
and I continue to get help if I need
help but I don't need any help I'm doing
well
I tell anyone out there that is
suffering from any type of mental
illness you can get help all you got to
do is ask and I will always always be a
champion for mental health and just to
clarify just to clarify how can Georgia
voters though be assured that this will
not impact your ability to lead if
elected because I'm ready to lead today
I'm ready to vote with the Georgia
voters whereas Senator why not has voted
with Joe Biden 96 percent of the time
I'm ready to vote with the Georgia
voters today open and shut the gentlemen
we'll move on to our next topic Tina and
that topic gentleman is health insurance
Georgia is one of 12 states that have
not accepted Federal funding to expand
Medicaid under the Affordable Care Act
Mr Walker with more than 1.5 million
Georgians uninsured and one minute
is it time for the federal government to
step in to ensure all Georgians have
access to health care well right now uh
people have coverage for Health Care is
according to what type of coverage do
you want no because if you have an
able-bodied job you're going to have
health care but everyone else have
health care is the type of health care
you're going to get that's something I
think that is the problem and what
Senator why not want you to do is depend
on the government what I want you to do
is get off the government health care
and get on the health care he's got to
get you a better health care so that's
what I'm trying to do to make you
independent rather than dependent it's
untrue and insane thank you Mr Walker
Senator warrenaka you have one minute
you've vowed to close the Medicaid Gap
by expanding access coverage in the
Affordable Care Act Marketplace is
Warner getting more difficult questions
the national debt already at an all-time
high
where is this money coming from you have
60 seconds Sir
this is not a theoretical issue for me
when I think about health care I think
about Lori Davis
a trauma nurse in Covington Georgia who
spent her career taking care of people
and then she got sick and she had to
give up that job and as she got sicker
and sicker
she found herself without Health Care
she was one of the six hundred thousand
Georgians in the Medicaid Gap
she died for lack of Health Care
and so I ran saying that I would fight
to expand Medicaid Georgia needs to
expand Medicaid it costs us more not to
expand what we're doing right now is
we're subsidizing Health Care in other
states meanwhile we've seen 10 hospitals
in this state close ten
and the Atlanta Medical Center right
down the street from my church where I
visit my members has announced that it's
going to close and so Georgia needs a
senator who believes like I do that
Health Care is a human right
and I will continue to fight until uh
the Working Class People by the way the
folks who don't have health care they
work every single day the folks were in
The Gap
let me finish let me finish the folks
who are in the gap
the folks who are in The Gap are the
working Port we are moving on Saturday
Mr Walker if I can get your attention
please in just a few weeks WellStar
we'll close its doors this is Atlanta
Medical Center which primarily serves to
patients and a lower income and minority
communities hospitals Nationwide are
dealing with nursing shortages doctor
shortages in the wake of the pandemic Mr
Walker what measures can Congress enact
to ensure everyone has access to
hospitals and doctors you have 30
seconds first of all Senator or not was
correct that he believed in working with
people but he didn't do it because
Governor Kemp has a plan that would have
been a very good plan but he stood back
while Biden destroyed the plan and he's
talking about he believes in the
extension of Governor he stood back well
what the people can be assured of is I'm
willing to meet with a hospital
administrator meet with people rather
than writing a letter because Senator
Walnut waited till they made the
decision and wrote a letter and I said
they don't need a PIN payout they need
they need Solutions
we are moving on now Sarah to Warnock
that same question to you sir what a
measures can Congress enact to ensure
everyone has access to hospitals and
doctors you have 30 seconds well clearly
he doesn't have a solution
well he said I'll meet with
administrator
his solution is to meet my solution is
to pass legislation which I've done
I got four billion dollars in the
American Rescue plan to help the
non-expansion states to do what they
should have done to expand they left
that money on the table Georgia left 600
000 Georgians in the Medicaid Gap and so
I'm going to keep standing up because
people are literally dying for lack of
Health Care Dr King said that of all the
injustices inequality in health care is
the most shocking and the most inhumane
I agree with Dr King thank you Senator
warrenaka buck
next topic thank you Tina we're going to
talk about foreign policy now Russian
President Vladimir Putin has threatened
to use nuclear weapons in the conflict
with Ukraine prompting President Biden
to claim that we are on the verge of
Armageddon Senator Warnock if nuclear
weapons are used how should the United
States respond you have 60 Seconds
well first of all I'm glad that we're
standing up
to Putin's aggression
and we have to continue to stand up
which is why I stood up to the Biden
Administration
when it suggested that we should close
the Savannah combat Readiness Training
Center
I told the president that was the exact
wrong thing to do at the exact wrong
time and I'm glad that I was able to
stand up with Congressman buddy Carter
and others and we kept that training
center open I've seen up close
what those service members do they are
the tip of the spear and we have to make
sure that our service members know that
we have their back we have to strengthen
our allies and the NATO alliance as
we've done and make sure we stand up to
Russian aggression nothing could be more
important Mr Walker the same question to
you if nuclear weapons are used how
should the U.S respond you have six well
first of all he talked about standing up
you didn't stand up to Chuck Schumer
when you could have got a helicopter uh
company here of almost a billion dollars
you let it go to New York you didn't
stand up then you didn't stand up to
Biden when he left American people and
had 13 military soldiers killed in
Afghanistan you didn't stand up then so
what we can do is Putin is a bully and
the way you beat a bullet show strength
well Senator why not say he stood up he
not stood up to Biden if he was standing
up he wouldn't have voted with him 96
percent of the time which gave us an
open it gave us an open border which
gave us High inflation which gave us
crime in the streets and he's talking
about standing up he didn't stand up he
had laid down every time it came around
and you know that senator
it is evident that he has a point that
he tries to make time and time again
I've stood up to the Biden
Administration so they could keep open
this combat training readiness Center
stood with our Congressional Delegation
to do that I've worked across the aisle
time and time to get good things done
for the people of Georgia I worked with
a senator from Texas to build out i-14 I
work for the Republican senator from
Alabama to help Georgia Farmers get
their products to Market
I will work with anyone and stand up
against anybody I need to stand up
against to get good things done for
Georgia I work for the people of Georgia
this is our next topic gentlemen where
our time is running short both of you
have strong backing from your respective
parties Senator Warnock a simple yes or
no here you will you will have a chance
to explain but I'd like a simple yes or
no would you support President Biden
running for a second term in 2024. I've
not spent a minute thinking about
what politicians should run for what in
2024 is that a yes or no the answer is I
have not
and and maybe this is difficult
maybe this is difficult for people to
understand because that's how
politicians think I think that part of
the problem with our politics right now
is that it's become too much about the
politicians you're asking me who's going
to run in 24. the people of Georgia get
to decide who's going to be their
senator in three days Monday and I hope
they'll show up and vote and I'd be
honored to represent them in the Senate
you haven't thought about it if you can
think about it now in 2024 the president
will turn 82 years old oh my God are you
concerned about his physical and his
mental Fitness at that time people of
Georgia
hired me
to represent them regardless of who's in
the White House
I'm I'm honored to do that job every
single day
my dad said if somebody hires you to do
a job do the job they hired you to do
they didn't hire me to be a pundit God
and I'm working every single day for
hard-working families in Georgia for our
women for our workers how is Biden
cognitive decline a topic in the Georgia
Senate debate Mr Walker former president
Trump is also considering a run for the
White House in 2024 if you can give me a
simple yes or no answer and we'll give
you time to explain as well would you
support a trump 2024 run yes I would and
let me take president Trump is my friend
has nothing to do with God has nothing
to do with that he's my friend how is
that relevant be my allies which is what
Senator Warner and Joe Biden did in
Afghanistan they left their allies they
left their allies and right now on a
foreign stage a lot of these people
don't trust us no more they don't trust
us to be strong anymore so they're
waiting to see who's going to stand up
who's going to trust and they have no
one to trust right now because I said
president Trump is my friend and he
won't stand up with Biden when yet he's
voted with him 96 percent of the time
let's be real
Mr Walker are you concerned about the
ongoing legal investigations around the
country and including here in Georgia
you have 30 seconds well first of all I
would hope that Senator why not he and
myself being people of color would want
the skills of Justice to have not have a
hand on it we want the
Lady Justice to be blind but in this
instance here later Justice is not blind
and I said right now with everything
that is going on what I like to do is
get to what's important what's important
is protecting the Border what's
important is protecting people on the
street what's important is getting this
inflation down not what's going on there
in Washington talking about whether
president Trump is guilty or not guilty
what I want to do is see due process
which is what I hope Senator why not
myself would love to see changing topics
now we're going to move forward just to
give you guys both an update that you
may want to know although the news is
not great if you're a Braves fan right
now they're in the top of the ninth
inning game three National League
Division Series down 9-1 to the Phillies
not a great night for the Braves just a
few weeks ago the World Series champs
though they did visit the White House
their visit sparked A Renewed debate
about the team's name and their
signature tomahawk chop Mr Walker do you
believe the brave should rethink their
name their logo or their signature cheer
you have 30 seconds not at all you know
right now we have too many other things
to be concerned about we have uh people
dying on the streets in Atlanta around
the country we have people living
paycheck the paycheck can't afford food
to put on their table can't afford gas
we have a Putin out there we have China
out there we can't be concerned about
whether the Braves going to change their
name we need to be concerned about
saving this country we need to be
concerned about saving the Georgia
people we need to be concerned about
giving people a right to live deliveries
and freedom that the Constitution of the
United States guarantees them to have
Senator Warnock the same question to you
what was the final regards to the Braves
do you think think they should rethink
their name their logo or their signature
cheer well first of all I'm praying for
the Braves right about now uh they
they've got a ways to go here
listen the the management of the Braves
is meeting with our tribes
and they're having a conversation about
this and I know the folks over at the
Braves organization and I trust that
they and the tribes that they're talking
to will come to a place that makes sense
for all involved
we're going to go ahead and continue we
want to get a few more questions in
tonight Senator Warnock some of your
Senate colleagues have called for
expanding the number of seats on the
Supreme Court in 15 seconds quickly sir
would you support this what I what I
support
expanding listen the seats on the
Supreme Court I think that my job as a
senator
is to protect the rights of ordinary
citizens and for the first time perhaps
in my lifetime we've seen those rights
contract rather than expand whether
we're talking about the Reproductive
Rights of women
or voting rights and I'm going to do
everything I can to protect the rights
of the citizens of Georgia Thank You
Senator Warnock Mr Walker would you
support expanding the number of seats
15 seconds Sir yes when you get in
Washington you have to become a leader
being a leader you have to make tough
tough uh decisions
he really didn't give you an answer so
my answer is no oh I wouldn't know
[Applause]
we have reached the point for a final
moments of this debate a chance for your
closing remarks you only have 60 seconds
each have 60 seconds to answer and
Senator Warren if you have the floor
first
well thank you so very much Georgia it's
wonderful uh to be here listen uh in
this state we have nearly 11 million
people
and only two people get to represent us
in the United States Senate just to
and when I think about that it is an
awesome responsibility
one that humbles me and inspires me to
work as hard as I can for hard-working
families every single day
and I've worked with Democrats and
Republicans in order to do that work
these are difficult times
these are dark times
but the scripture says that the light
shines in the darkness and the Darkness
overcometh it not I'm honored to
represent you in the Senate I hope that
you'll show up to vote early beginning
Monday I'd be honored to have you vote
God bless you keep your faith Mr Walker
your turn for closing statements and you
have 60 seconds as well
for those of you who are concerned about
uh voting for me a non-politician
I want you to think about the damage
politicians like Joe Biden the Rafael
want to have done to this country
I want you to think about Raphael one of
what he said today and I said he was
going to try to give you some smooth
talk
and tell you what's happening what's
happening is this country is hurting
what's happening is we need leaders
so what I want to say to you Senator why
not
is I want to thank you
I want to thank you for this
but at the same time I want to say
Georgia need leaders they need leaders
that's going to stand up for them so
let's think about if we give Senator War
not six more years
think of what this country will become
I'm not sure if we can make up for that
gentlemen I said vote for Herschel
Walker thank you both gentlemen that's
going to conclude our debate for this
evening
before we leave tonight though we want
to remind voters that early voting
begins in Georgia on Monday it will run
through November 4th election day is
November 8th candidates thank you and we
of course want to thank plant Riverside
so listen
Walker is a disaster I mean painfully
disastrous Warnock is not the strongest
candidate and there were some very clear
questions here
where Warnock did not seem particularly
prepared
um
but Walker is really a disaster I mean
it's like warnock's just kind of like an
okay candidate
if Walker were to win it's sort of like
a global humiliation for the United
States and the moderators could not have
been worse this was one of the worst
moderated debates like Warnock did
mediocre
Walker is an unmitigated disaster the
moderation was terrible
and I I mean it's just it's just
stunning stunning stuff
um
let's see what the polling looks like uh
in a few days and whether this moves it
as of right now Warnock plus 3.3
um George is a runoff state
so if indeed on November 8th it's 48 45
with the rest of the vote going
elsewhere there will be a runoff and
that would not be particularly good for
Raphael Warnock so this is going to be
uh this is going to be a fight this is
going to be a fight that is for damn
sure thank you to S Prez for nine Gifted
memberships dumping Us in right at 100
exactly where we needed it to be I
appreciate everybody who joined me make
sure you are subscribed on YouTube and
following on Twitch and liked on YouTube
so that when we do the next debate which
might be Marco Rubio which is not going
to be one you want to miss uh you'll be
notified appreciate everybody joining me
what an incredible incredible day
are you looking for a place to watch
some news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know of a guy who fits
that bill of progressive with political
will but David pectin shows you your
political knowledge sign up for a
membership now for the bonus show that's
best in town who's the current president
of the United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
[Music]
will you tell me I mean is there a
president right now I guess
um well
answer that how's that organization
[Music]
I've been growing this one huge heifer
all summer
it's time to pluck it
[Music]